Thomas Jane actually stabbed a guy in
the chest and Joe Pesci gave Macaulay
Culkin a permanent scar with his teeth
think acting is all fake these actors
have the hospital bills to prove it
isn't it's tough to be James Bond sure
you get the cool cars the high-tech
gadgets and the Slick tuxedos but you
also have to contend with any number of
villainous henchmen assassins and thugs
prepared to batter you senseless at
every turn stunt work on Bond films has
always been intense but the franchise's
fight scenes have grown particularly
brutal in their execution during Daniel
Craig's tenure and he's got the wounds
to prove it during the filming of
Specter Craig went toe-to-toe with
professional wrestler turned actor Dave
Batista during a fight scene that was
supposed to take place on a moving train
at one point Batista threw Craig across
the train car and while the move was
planned the way Craig landed was not
Craig tore a meniscus in his knee and
had to take two weeks off from filming
for arthroscopic surgery he doesn't
blame him though and in fact he
accidentally got his Revenge by breaking
Batista's nose when they later reshot
the scene I threw this punch I hit him
on the nose and I heard this crack and I
went oh God no one ran away
professional wrestling Legend Jerry The
King Lawler once famously feuded with
the iconic and infamously
confrontational comedian Andy Kaufman 16
years after that Lawler was called upon
to recreate the feud by playing himself
in the Kaufman biopic man on the moon
this time Lawler would be acting
opposite star Jim Carrey who's only
supposed to be pretending to be Kaufman
Carrie took his role very seriously
though and things got real for Lawler
once again even more real than they had
ever been with Kaufman as covered in the
documentary Jim and Andy the great
beyond Carrie was relentlessly devoted
to playing Kaufman remaining in
character during the entire production
of man on the moon to the point that he
puzzled and often frustrated his
collaborators things sometimes got
heated and that included scenes with
Lawler at one point during the
production Carrie in character as
Kaufman spit out the wrestler prompting
Lawler to get physical the exact nature
of the injury isn't clear but it was
enough to briefly land carry in a
hospital even years later Lawler was
still expressing his unease at how far
Carrie took everything well Jim Carrey's
an idiot though the rocky films are
often very melodramatic and bombastic in
their portrayal of the title character's
story Creator Sylvester Stallone still
always wanted to aim for some level of
realism during the making of the series
in Rocky IV in which his character faces
Russian boxer Ivan Drago on a quest to
avenge the death of his friend Apollo
Creed Stallone Drew inspiration from a
real-life boxing match featuring two
fighters who hated each other outside of
the Ring reasoning that Rocky and Drago
would also hate each other Stallone
instructed actor Dolph Lundgren to
actually hit him during the opening
moments of their fight
let's see as requested Lundgren Came Out
Swinging and he hit Stallone so hard in
the chest that he had to cut the scene
short Stallone knew the punches were
serious but he didn't know how serious
until later that night when his blood
pressure shot up and he had to be flown
from Canada back to the United States
for emergency medical treatment Stallone
later explained he hit my heart so hard
that it banged against my ribs and
started to swell and that usually
happens in car accidents actors
understand that injuries can happen
during intense sequences particularly
when the make-believe of a scene
involves a physical struggle sometimes
though the real drama of a moment lives
on long after it's committed to film
this was the case with Gothica the 2003
Thriller that earned a lot of coverage
in the entertainment press thanks to an
onset injury during a scene in which her
character Dr Miranda gray is being
interrogated star Halle Berry was
supposed to struggle against co-star
Robert Downey Jr who was supposed to
attempt to restrain her Barry approached
the scene with such intent density that
Downey accidentally broke a bone in her
forearm while trying to hold her back
the injury made headlines and Downey was
frequently asked to the point of
frustration to explain what happened
while he tried to promote the film in
one of those interviews he told IGN I
would say to her listen you're a badass
but you weigh 102 pounds and your bones
are as thin as like Crayolas then I turn
out to be the Apple who's like trying to
put her arm down with my hand open and I
feel her own a snap Channing Tatum
received some of the best reviews of his
career for director Bennett Miller's
2014 drama Fox catcher which was based
on true events that happened at John
DuPont's self-funded wrestling training
facility in the 1990s as Olympic
wrestler Mark Schultz Tatum worked hard
to reach a certain level of realism and
intensity in each scene and it sometimes
cost him in one memorable moment Tatum
slammed his head so hard through a prop
mirror that he hit the wall behind it
leaving him with a cut in another
Tatum's demand for intensity led to yet
another injury this time at the hands of
co-star Mark Ruffalo who played Mark's
brother and Coach Dave Schultz for a
scene in which Dave slaps Mark upside
the head Tatum asked Ruffalo to hit him
for real Ruffalo did but Tatum
immediately regretted his request Tatum
told variety he pops my eardrum all of a
sudden it's just making a screeching
noise I can't hear anything Tatum's
eardrum ultimately healed but the look
of pain on his face in the finished film
after Ruffalo slapped him was definitely
not acting AMC's massive zombie Hit The
Walking Dead is an intense show full of
shocking death scenes and Undead battles
and of course brawls between it's often
at odds human characters as the show's
leading man Andrew Lincoln was often at
the Forefront of these confrontations
and he took his job seriously according
to co-star Norman Reedus in an attempt
to keep his energy High Lincoln would
often get very caffeinated before the
show's most intense scenes this plus
Lincoln's tendency toward clumsiness
what sometimes lead to his co-stars
unceremoniously getting punched in the
face Reed is described one such
encounter on The Tonight Show starring
Jimmy Fallon he's supposed to run and
tackle me off camera right just jump
into an airbag but he jumps and he
punches me in the face with double fists
and that was apparently far from the
only accidental injury linking caused
Regis noted that Lincoln had developed
quite the reputation for his accidental
punches it was such an issue that
Jeffrey Dean Morgan who plays Negan on
the show called rate US up one night to
express his dread over shooting a fight
scene with link in the following day the
result about what you'd expect according
to a photo Morgan texted read us the
following day it's Jeff with a Band-Aid
on his nose with an ice pack right no
yeah he points up in the nose anyone
who's ever seen Goodfellas knows that
Oscar winner Joe Pesci is an actor with
a talent for playing very scary
characters and it's a skill that Pesci
himself apparently takes quite seriously
even when he's using it for a light
family comedy in the holiday Classic
Home Alone Pesci plays Harry the smarter
and more Savage of the two Bandits who
attempt to terrorize and Rob Macaulay
Culkin's Kevin McAllister only to find
that he's more than they bargained for
you guys give up or you're thirsty for
more though he's ultimately playing an
overconfident buffoon peshi still felt
he needed to make Culkin uncomfortable
during their scenes together in fact he
deliberately kept his distance from The
Young star on set until it was time to
actually play the scary bad guy but even
peshi didn't mean to go quite as far as
he did in one scene during their final
confrontation after the bandits catch
Kevin and prepared to pay him back for
all the pain he's caused them Harry
threatens to bite off all of the boy's
fingers in the film he never actually
gets to as Kevin is saved at the last
moment in real life Pesci accidentally
bit Culkin during one take and left a
permanent scar it broke the skin and
everything I'm a little nine-year-old
boy and he's going around biting him you
know yeah and I still I still have the
scar most of the time when an actor
injures one of their co-stars it's an
accident other times it's the product of
setco star demanding to be struck for
the sake of realism then there are those
rare moments like one that happened on
the set of the Texas Chainsaw Massacre
when someone just really wants to get
the scene over with the famous dinner
scene in Leatherface's house in the
Texas Chainsaw Massacre was filmed in
one Marathon shooting day in an
unair-conditioned house in the
Relentless summer heat the actors were
covered in sweat the stench in the room
was overpowering and everyone involved
was beginning to go a little crazy as
they were pushed to their working limits
this craziness ultimately manifested
itself as a real injury during the
moment in which Gunner Hansen's
Leatherface Cuts Sally's finger to feed
her blood to Grandpa the blade of the
knife was covered with tape to make it
dull and Hansen was supposed to pretend
to cut actress Marilyn Burns then
squeeze a bulb full of fake blood
concealed in his hand to make it look
like Burns was bleeding according to a
2003 DVD commentary track when the tube
that was supposed to squirt out the
blood kept clogging Hanson got so
frustrated that he pulled the tape off
and cut Burns for real just to get the
scene over with in 1995 the Mortal
Kombat film roundhouse kicked its way
into theaters and into the hearts of
moviegoers around the globe while
expectation were low especially since
the video game movie Curse was still in
full effect fans were blown away by The
Fierce and thrilling action on display
part of the reason the film worked is
because director Paul W S Anderson
employed actual fighting experts in
pivotal parts for the role of the
spectral fire-breathing ninja scorpion
anderson-hired martial artist and
stuntman Chris casamassa one of the best
fight scenes of the film takes place
between Lyndon Ashby's Johnny Cage and
casimasu Scorpion get over here
the two begin their battle in a forest
before being transported to another
Eerie Dimension concluding the bout in
fiery fashion it's a brutal exchange of
fists and kicks and one of casimasu's
attacks actually left Ashby in
considerable pain speaking to The
Hollywood Reporter Ashby explained how
casimasa helped him prepare for the
fight scenes but he said there was an
unintentional accident Chris did an ax
kick to my kidneys in that fight I had a
pad on but his heel just came right
between the pads and got me in the
kidney hard I was peeing blood it hurt a
lot not quite a fatality but definitely
painful as the star of 2010's The
Expendables Sylvester Stallone got to
test his medal alongside other action
heroes like Dolph Lundgren Jet Li and
Jason Statham however it wasn't any of
them who caused damage to slide this
time around only an idiot would do this
job how much oh like I said
during the movie Stallone's Barney Ross
squares off against Stone Cold Steve
Austin's aptly named character Payne
Austin of course is well known for his
mud hole stomping and Stone Cold
stunners in the WWE it appears as if the
Texas rattlesnake brought the same
energy to his performance here but it
left Stallone a little worse for wear in
the end speaking to FHM magazine
Stallone revealed the intensity of the
fight scenes in the film including one
that left him needing surgery afterward
actually my fight with Stone Cold Steve
Austin was so vicious that I ended up
getting a hairline fracture in my neck
I'm not joking I haven't told anyone
this but I had to have a very serious
operation afterwards I now have a metal
plate in my neck in 2020 Halle Berry
marked her directorial debut with the
Netflix Sports drama bruised Barry also
stars in the film as MMA fighter Jackie
pretty bull Justice expectedly she gets
the opportunity to show what she is made
of in a few scenes in bruised Justice's
main opponent is Lucia lady killer
Chavez portrayed by real-life UFC
fighter Valentina shevchenko speaking to
Sports Illustrated Barry revealed that
chefchenko played a major part in
ensuring she was prepared for the film
by training her the actor also said that
they decided to film their big fight
early in the production which was when
Barry quickly found out just how painful
MMA can really be Barry said on day two
I got kicked and broke two ribs and you
know there was a moment when I thought
we can shut this down and I can go heal
or I can keep going and just fight my
way through it however the actor decided
against it considering all the time that
both she and chefchenko had invested in
the training as well as how a delay
could result in the entire film being
canceled so she pushed through the pain
to film the fight saying she waited
until they had the scene before telling
anyone about her injury for Ryan
coogler's Creed a decision was made to
take the realism to the next level by
casting real boxers in the film Michael
B Jordan's Adonis Creed steps into the
ring against Pretty Ricky conlon who was
portrayed by a real-life champion boxer
Tony bellew much like Sylvester Stallone
took a proper Hook from Dolph Lundgren
in Rocky IV Jordan tasted a knuckle
sandwich in the movie courtesy of value
appearing on The Graham Norton Show
Jordan revealed that there was a need to
get footage of him taking a punch for a
slow motion sequence there is no way to
fake that type of scene so he had to
take a real punch from his co-star twice
[Applause]
while Jordan said he didn't quite get
knocked out he did feel the impact
adding it felt like I was in a car
accident for like four days afterward
Tony said he only went 40 percent it
felt like 85. it was tough
compared to other films mentioned here
Francis Ford Coppola's The Godfather
isn't exactly bursting with intense
action that should result in broken
bones and busted lips sure there's
violence on display but there should be
no reason for the actress to suffer any
onset injuries apart from a freak
accident however the memorable scene
where Sunny Corleone lays into his
brother-in-law Carlo carries a bit more
bite because of the real-life Bad Blood
between the actors apparently James Khan
and Gianni Russo had developed some
hostility toward each other throughout
the production of the 1972 film they
still rehearsed their big scene but when
it came down to the day of the shoot
Khan started to do things differently
and more viciously Russo explained to
Entertainment Weekly he improvised a few
things like that little billy club he
threw at me when I came off the stoop he
hit me right in the head with that and
then he throws me over the railing and
he's biting my hands none of that was
supposed to happen when I crawl out
he literally lift me up with his kick
Russo added that the beating beating him
with injuries including broken ribs and
a chipped elbow the story of 1989 cyborg
merits a book while it might appear like
one of the Canon group's trademark low
budget action films there's a lot of
history behind how this production came
to be the short of it is that Canon
planned to shoot Spider-Man and Masters
of the Universe 2 at the same time to
cut costs but plans fell apart since
Canon had already spent the money on
costumes and props filmmaker Albert puhn
wrote a script over a weekend that
became cyborg Jean-Claude Van Damme
signed up to play the lead role of
Gibson Rickenbacker and it was Off to
the Races as with any film featuring Van
Damme cyborg is all about the action and
there are countless fight scenes in the
movie in one of the sequences Van
Damme's character battles a gang of
pirates one of whom is played by former
bodybuilder Jackson Rock Pinckney
unfortunately an accident occurred when
a prop knife went into pinckney's eye
according to the Orlando Sentinel
Pinckney sued and was awarded 480 7 500
in Damages
Rob Reiner's The Princess Bride is a
beloved 1987 fantasy film that has stood
the test of time what can I do for you
you can die slowly cut into a thousand
pieces
it's a riveting action-adventure story
that follows Wesley as he tries to
rescue the love of his life princess
Buttercup it boasts plenty of exciting
action sequences but the scene that
knocked actor Carrie Elway's out cold
came during a relatively tame moment it
happens during a scene in which count
rugin puts Wesley down for the count by
bonking his head with the handle of his
sword according to Elvis's book as you
wish inconceivable Tales from the making
of The Princess Bride Christopher Guest
who played rugin had no intention of
harming him with his metal sword in the
scene the problem was it didn't look
great on camera so Elvis said he
encouraged guests to slightly tap his
head and he would move El was wrote
Chris swung the heavy sword down toward
my head however as fate would have it it
landed Just a Touch harder than either
of us anticipated and that folks was the
last thing I remember from that day's
shoot I woke up in the hot
with stitches being
where am I and the scene
the scene in fact me being knocked out
for real on a more lighthearted note the
most famous injury in The Princess Bride
didn't come from any physical
altercation whatsoever it happened
during the scene in which Inigo and
fezik take Wesley to be healed by
Miracle Max played by Billy Crystal
Crystal improvised much of his material
as Max churning out jokes on the set for
three days while his co-stars fought to
hold in their laughter during filming in
many cases they were unsuccessful Drake
and character during takes because
Crystal was just too funny Mandy
Patinkin in particular though really
wanted to make it through the scenes
without laughing and it cost him by the
time filming was done the effort
actually gave him a physical injury the
only injury I sustained on that movie
was I bruised a rib from holding in my
laughter with Billy Crystal and that's
the God's honest truth if Sean beam is
in a movie chances are his character
won't make it to the final credits no
matter if he's a good or bad guy beans
on-screen personas seem to be fated to
dance with the Grim Reaper under the
pale moonlight in 1992's Patriot Games
Bean's character Sean Miller doesn't
make it out alive either unsurprisingly
though in this case he is the villain so
no one can be too upset about Harrison
Ford's Jack Ryan putting him in a watery
grave Miller and Ryan have an
exhilarating final encounter on a moving
speedboat throughout the Clash Ryan
looks to be on the back foot and
overpowered by Miller however the cia's
favorite Child perseveres and puts his
opponent down once and for all as being
revealed on the complete Sean Bean the
scuffle between him and Ford resulted in
him receiving the infamous scar on his
face while shooting the scene Ford
accidentally hit him with a bow tuck
which cut just under Bean's left eyebrow
The Punisher is finally getting its
flowers years after its 2004 release
starring Thomas Jane as Frank Castle it
is a bloody good time that doesn't shirk
away from violent encounters and manages
to capture the tone of the comic book
character it might not have the body
count of Marvel's next big screen stab
at the character 2008's Punisher warzone
own but it did feature its own literal
onset stabbing appearing on the Rich
Eisen show Jane revealed that someone
had forgotten to replace the real knife
with the prop so during the scene where
Castle fights the hulking Russian played
by ex-pro wrestler Kevin Nash Jane stabs
Nash in the chest with an actual knife
it stabs him and it goes in and I'm
looking at the knife I'm looking at him
Kevin he's just looking down at me and
I'm look there's a knife sticking out of
his chest the actor said he expected
Nash to lash out and react in anger but
Nash didn't nonetheless Jane said he
still felt terrible about it for his
part Nasha said that he doesn't hold any
grudges about what happened but he says
that the people in charge of props
should be doing their jobs more
diligently to avoid these types of
incidents from occurring he just sat
there and looked at the knife looked at
me
I sent him a couple cases of beer
Bloodsport is widely seen as the film
that catapulted Jean-Claude Van Damme
into super stardom and it's also
recognized as one of the greatest
martial arts movies of all time while
most fans remember Bloodsport for the
vicious final fight there is another
Swift battle that stands out albeit for
a different reason an earlier fight
scene with actor Bernard Mariano ends
with him making one last attempt to get
Van Damme who puts him back down with a
chop to the face the scene looks great
on film however it wasn't the best time
for Mariano speaking to South China
Morning Post Mariano explained when we
rolled the first take he moved too fast
he was already moving back and caught me
full on the jaw and split my lip I
passed out and was taken to hospital and
stitched up Mariano insisted that the
blood on the mat which appears in the
Final Cut was actually his own